[Musique]
vous aurez peut-être la chance de
croiser un petit personnage bien
familier en visitant l'exposition légaux
architecture du château chan aurier à
croissy-sur-seine à les tâches d'abord
avec un petit saut entre l'imaginaire
légaux et la pop culture elle a beaucoup
aimé cette salle avec le côté coloré
qu'on avait beaucoup moins en bas et
puis dans l'imaginaire les deux dents
aussi on se retrouve dans dans un monde
où l'on rêve beaucoup
là où il ya plein de petites scènes de
vie mais harry peut aussi se cacher du
côté du réel avec deux salles une dédiée
à la france et ses monuments et une
deuxième pièce à côté vous allez faire
un tour du monde donc en passant par
sydney et dubaï
vous allez passer par l'egypte etc et
puis dans la salle dite noire alors là
je vais pas tout vous dévoiler vous
allez avoir la salle harry potter mais
il faut rester dans la surprise pour
harry potter parce qu'en fait vous avez
une château d'harry potter il ya
tellement de choses à voir dedans avec
sa cinquantaine d'oeuvres cette balade
nostalgique au pays de la construction
d'un qu'un seul objectif mêler les
générations justement donc les plus
adultes entre guillemets vont se régaler
avec l' architecture et les enfants vont
se régaler avec l'architecturé avec leur
monde a eu pour votre visite harry
devrait bien être du côté de poudlard
mais qui sait peut-être préférera-t-il
vous attendre à un autre endroit
[Musique]